sorry dass ich dich dass du mir dein
herz ausschüttet ja was immer das
bedeutet dass du über deine probleme
redet aber das ist okay ich hätte das
einfach nicht von carla erwartet von mag
natürlich schon da ist so ein kerl ich
freue mich ganz nett du vielleicht jetzt
bleibt man ganz cool
bist du dir denn sicher dass carla
wusste was du für marc empfindest naja
ich hast du jemals deutlich gesagt dass
wir ihn natürlich nicht
ich habe mit niemandem darüber
gesprochen außer mit lena und dir jetzt
ich weiß einfach nicht was ich machen
soll dass ben der mir die schönsten mail
schreibt aber mich anscheinend nicht
sehen will das macht doch keinen sinn
und dann ist da mag den kann ich zwar
anfassen aber verstehen könnte ich es
ziemlich sexy wie meinst du das mit
sexy
ich bin schwul
das habe ich gar nicht gemerkt na ja ich
wollte kein t shirt tragen auf dem was
draufsteht und hast du einen freund zur
zeit nicht aber es wäre mal wieder einer
zeit
na ja ausnahmsweise bin ich mal froh
darüber wenn ich heute noch ein
glückliches paar sie werde ich
wahnsinnig